bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
semaine qui débute sur TVfil 78 nous
sommes le lundi 22 septembre dans votre
journal d'information locale ce soir la
manif pour tout ce qui refait parler
d'elle les opposants au mariage
homosexuel organise une conférence débat
au chînet à 20h30 pour qu la théorie du
genre à l'école dimanche 5 octobre
mobilisation contre la GPA qui se
déroulera notamment à Paris invité
ludovine de la rocher la présidente
nationale du mouvement Nicolas Sarkozi
revient en politique il vise la
présidence de l'UMP et pourquoi pas 2017
son retour divise jusque dans sa famille
politique parmi sa nouvelle garde
rapprochée se trouve en tout cas Aurore
berger responsable de l'opposition au
conseil municipal de manie Lamo dans les
ivelines donc et puis hon courour les
opposants au projet d'une piste de ski
couverte profite des journées du PAT
patrimoine pour mobiliser ils étaient ce
weekend au sommet de la colline
d'lancour prévention routière pour
débuter la massif organise en
partenariat avec la police nationale
deux journées de mobilisation à
l'attention des deux roues les agents
étaient présents toute la journée ils
seront là aussi demain devant l'espace
550 an à guuille en cours les usagers
pourront s'informer des règles de
sécurité adoptées sur la route ils
pourront aussi échanger sur leur
équipement et l'entretien de leur
véhicules nous avons convié nos
sociétaires à
venir présenter leur motos deç son avoir
les 10 points essentiels qui peuvent
faire défaut sur une moto genre tension
de chaîne disque de frein plaquette et
cetera et leur donner des conseils sur
naturellement l'équipement du motard qui
est à notre avis indispensable ça peut
toucher une population qui ne qui ne
sait pas encore qu'il faut qu'il faut
rouler protéger c'est-à-dire au moins
avec un minimum d'équipement ils ont
pour l'événement un panneau qui est très
bien fait qui
justement quels sont les les organes à
entretenir sur une motoussi c'est
important de bien être équipé même quand
on fait 10 km pour aller au travail pour
justement un petit peu endiguer et
surtout se protéger par rapport à un
accident éventuel avec les pompiers
quand on intervient sur des accidents de
la route malheureusement les motards en
font les frais et c'est survant des
accidents très graves propos recueilli
par William l'invité du journal ludovine
de la RER bonsoir vous êtes la
présidente nation de la manif pour tous
pour ceux qui ne vous connaissent pas
brièvement vous avez été enseignante
vous êtes catholique vous avez de fortes
convictions mais pour autant pas de
militantisme à proprement parler été
2013 vous devenez donc la présidente de
la manif pour tous avec le départ où
lesviction c'est selon les versions de
frigide bargeot aujourd'hui vous en est
toute cette transition alors je précise
que d'abord j'ai fondé la BIF pour tous
avec frigide bargeot et alberérique
Dumont et j'en ai été la présidente à
partir de janvier 2013 aujourd'hui vous
en êtes la présidente mais il y avait
frgide bardeau auparavant sur mon
rapport mon rapport avec elle
aujourd'hui comment ça écout frigide a
créé un autre mouvement qui s'appelle
l'avenir pour tous et pour autant elle
fait toujours partie de l'association de
la manif pour tous t qu'elle est venue à
la dernière assemblée générale et nous
avons échangé sur nos sujets donc tout
se passe bien entre vous écoutez ça se
passe normalement alors j'aimerais
qu'elle soit moins critique dans ses
propos publices à l'égard de la manie
pour tous mais ça va s'apaiser en tout
cas c'est bien vous donc qui tiendrez ce
soir en chaîner une conférence débat à
partir de 20h30 c'est à l'ancienne
mairie le thème la théorie du genre à
l'école myth ou réalité on va y venir
for forcément mais tout d'abord
concernant le mariage pour tous votre
réaction aux déclarations de Nicolas
Sarkozi hier sur France 2 il n'a pas dit
clairement s'il abrogerait ou non cette
loi du mariage pour tous en tout cas il
a dit que il n'opposerait pas les
familles aux homosexuels ni les
homosexuels aux familles qu'en avez-vous
pensé alors pour reprendre cette
dernière phrase j'ai été très mal à
l'aise avec cette phrase parce que dans
les familles et dans nos rangs et dans
nos porte-paroles il y a il y avait et
il y a toujours des personnes
homosexuelles autrement dit c'est pas
parce qu'on est homosexuel qu'on est
pour le mariage entre a personnes de
même sexe ça c'est un premier point bon
mais par ailleurs que ce sujet soit
évoqué dans cet entretien qui était un
entretien important très important avec
des enjeux présents et d'avenir
évidemment est très significatif de ce
que le sujetue à faire débat continue à
diviser les Français du fait de Monsieur
Hollande qui n'a pas voulu les entendre
et c'est bien un enjeu aujourd'hui comme
ça le sera donc aujourd'hui là en
l'occurrence pour la présidence de l'UMP
comme ça le sera très clair
en 2017 ceci dit la présidentielle 2017
on a encore un petit peu de temps à
attendre avant et puis les candidats
faudra bien évidemment attendre de voir
qui sera déclarer auou non Nicolas
Sarkozi ou pas d'ailleurs mais vous
pensez qu'un nouveau président 2017
pourrait faire marchine arrière revenir
sur cette loi si vous voulez c'est ce
que nous avons toujours dit le mariage
c'est c'est une institution qui a été
qui est reconnue par la loi parce que
c'est pour s'aimer mais ça ça regarde
pas l'état ça ça regarde les personnes
elles-mêmes et c'est pour fonder une
famille et donc euh la loi est là et
d'ailleurs l'essentiel de de ce que lit
un mère au moment de la célébration d'un
mariage concerne les enfants hein la
finalité du mariage c'est celle-ci même
si malheureusement parfois il y a des
familles qui des couples qui n'ont pas
d'enfants deux personnes de même sexe ne
peuvent pas avoir d'enfant ensemble
elles doivent avoir recours euh à un
donneur elles doivent avoir recours à un
médecin un intervenant un technicien
l'adoption euh alors on évoquera
l'adoption ensuite
euh mais autrement dit le mariage ne
convient pas aux personnes aux couples
de même sexe et c'est pour cela que la
raison reste que la que le sujet pardon
reste bien d'actualité tout le monde
s'interroge encore sur cette questionl
et cela se poursuivra très certainement
nous nous pensons puisque bien sûr le
mariage c'est donc l'affiliation cela
veut dire que avec le mariage entre
personnes de même sexe viennent et
viennent déjà concrètement la PMA pour
les couples de femmes et la gestation
pour autrui h euh qui sont des pratiques
qui privent l'enfant de père ou de mère
donc le mariage si je suis votre
raisonnement la final c'est uniquement
pour une finalité pour avoir des enfants
le mariage dans la dimension qui regarde
l' hétérosexuels ne peuvent pas avoir
d'enfants si on suit cette logique ils
ne peuvent pas se marier non plus non
bien sûr que non parce que d'abord quand
on se marie malheureusement c'est
ensuite qu'on s'aperçoit qu'on peut pas
avoir d'enfant mais de toute façon on
est dans une perspective de vie commune
de vie ensemble avec un projet et en
particulier ce projet de fondir une
famille c'est ce qui caractérise le
mariage même si on peut fonder une
famille en dehors du
mariage et les sentiments qu'on a l'un à
l'égard de l'autre quand on se marie
c'est pas ça qui intéresse l'officier
d'état civil et c'est pas ça qui
intéresse la loi c'est pas la question
sceller les personnes homosexuelles vous
répondront qu'elles veulent sceller leur
union signifier qu'elles s'iment et
qu'elles veulent vivre ensemble qu'elles
puissent ou non avoir des enfants comme
les personnes marage le mariage et
encore une fois l'officier d'état civil
le maire quand il célèbre un mariage
l'essentiel des articles de du Code
civil qu'il lit concerne les enfants à
venir h euh voilà or il n'y a pas de
filiation qui ne viennent pas d'un homme
et d'une femme de l'union d'un homme et
d'une femme qu'il s'aime c'est tout à
fait tout à fait entendable légitime et
cetera bien sûr mais en 2017 la loi est
revue la loi est abrogée les couples qui
ont pu se marier pendant cette période
il peut pas y avoir rétroactivité bien
sûr que non humainement ce serait
impossable cré dans la société une
situation peu particulière avec des
personnes qui ont pu se marier d'autres
qui ne pourront plus moi je vais vous
parler des enfants et il y a eu des
centaines d'adoptions euh depuis le vote
de la loi tobira des centaines
d'adoptions par des couples de deux
femmes d'enfants nés de PMA à l'étranger
et qu'on a donc définitivement privé de
paè moi je crois que le plus grave il
est là ces enfants qu'on prive de paè
père et mère c'est différent père et
mère on a besoin des deux et d'abord
pour naître on a besoin d'un père et
d'une mère et ensuite euh euh et et dans
la suite pour se construire et cetera
bien sûr deux femmes peuvent aimer
beaucoup un enfant bien sûr elles
peuvent être merveilleuses elles peuvent
être maternelles mais deux femmes ne
remplaceront jamais un père et
réciproquement en relançant le débat
aujourd'hui de de telle manière en
l'alimentant encore jusqu'à même 2017
avec la prochaine présidentielle on
n'avait pas peur de relancer aussi une
vague d'homophobie parce qu'il y a eu
des fait homophobe il y a eu des
violences contre les personnes
homosexuelles pendant ces débats ça a
cristallisé certaines violences
certaines tensions soit verbal que ce
soit physique qu message vous appelz
aujourd'hui à faire passerux ch deux
choses d'abord le clivage n'est pas ne
vient pas de l' manif pour tous il vient
du projet de Monsieur Hollande il faut
bien mettre les responsabilités là où
elle se
trouve attendez pour le moment je parle
du clivage dans la société française
ensuite la manif pour tous a toujours
toujours condamné sans cesse sans
relâche tout propos homophobe
c'est-à-dire tout propos qui exprime un
manque de respect et même d'amitié à
l'égard d'une personne au motif de son
orientation sexuelle ça c'est une chose
et je condamne toute forme d'homophobie
ensuite la LGBT vous le vous savez bien
est un lobby ultra minoritaire qui ne
représente pas l'ensemble qui ne
représente pas l'ensemble des personnes
homosexuelles ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que c'est pas parce qu'on est
opposé aux revendications du lobby LGBT
sur des revendications qui regardent
toute la société française qu'on
peut-être qualifier d'homophobe il y a
une confusion et confusion qui nous
empêche de nous exprimer une vague une
une vague homophobe avec des propos qui
étaient pas toujours très clair farait
bien distinguer les choses parce que si
on qualifie d'homophobe le fait et je
l'ai bien vécu moi hein s'opposer au
mariage entre personnes de même sexe
dire c'est de l'homophobie c'est faux et
ça vise quoi à nous empêcher de nous
exprimer alors que nous disons très
simplement un enfant né d'un homme et
d'une femme il a besoin d'un père et
d'une mère c'est quand même j'allais
dire de bon sens alors après qu'il y ait
des propos qui manqueent de respect
encore une fois à l'égard d'une personne
auotif qu'elle est homosexuel me choque
profondément mais il faut pas faire
d'amalgame euh sur cette question qui
est très importante vous allez vous
exprimer en tout cas ce soir auchînet
lors de la conférence débat auchînet une
ville où il devrait pas y avoir trop
d'opposition on se souvient que cette
commune avait rassemblé avec grâce à son
maire les différentes manifestations
mobilisation il y a une pétition aussi
lors de la saisie de du Conseil d'État
euh au final ce sera une discussion à
sens unique ce soir alors c'est une
conférence hein donc il y aura trois
intervenantes une sexologue et puis une
responsable du mouvement Vigi gender qui
est un mouvement spécialiste de ces
question du genre à l'école ils ont un
réseau de parents et puis moi-même qui
interviendrai également mais je voudrais
revenir sur la question de de la loi
tobira la PMA aujourd'hui est un sujet
actuel c'est pas légalisation ou pas
demain ou après demain aujourd'hui
encore une fois des centaines
d'adoptions plinières ont été reconnues
à des couples de femmes la gestation
pour autrui elle est tolérée par le
gouvernement actuel monsieur Holland
avait dit est interite franis Hollande a
dit qu'elle ne s'attendait pas durant
son mandat dans les faites elle n'est
pas interdite la circulaire tobira
permet d'avoir recours facilite le
recours à des mères porteuses à
l'étranger alors je voudrais quand même
dire une chose très allez-y oneviendra
ensuite parce qu'on va être pris par le
temps sur sur le thème de V j'ai entendu
les ministres vous avez raison j'ai
entendu les ministres madame tomira
madame na Valou belcassem il y en a sans
doute d'autres qui disent les enfants
nés des GPA à l'étranger sont apatrid je
cite anonym petit fantôme de la
République mais c'est faux il la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme a
condamné la France parce qu'il fallait
que la France les reconnaisse qu'
n'était pas mais c'est pas parce que la
Cour européenne des droits de l'homme
émet une condamnation que la France ne
peut pas faire appel de cette
condamnation parce que j'insiste tous
les enfants comme vous comme moi nés de
GPA ou pas tous les enfants ont l'état
civil et la nationalité de leur pays de
naissance autrement dit prendre pour
prétexte de la circulaire tobira que ses
enfants seraient apatrid et soit de la
compétence très grave parce que elles en
font un argument
régulièrement soit malhonnête non le
vrai le véritable enjeu de la circulaire
tobira c'est d'inscrire une filiation
fausse en partie ou en totalité dans
l'état civil et d'inscrire l'affiliation
qui convient aux clients de la mère
porteuse il faut dire les choses et il
faut débattre à partir de ce qui est
réellement voà juste le combat contre la
GPA et de l'ampleur de ceux qui ont mené
à l'abolition de l'esclavage ou de la
parti ce sont vos propos rapportés par
BFM RMC vous les maintenz servement
garder mais attendez la gestation pour
autrui les maères porteuses c'est la
location de l'utérus de la femme c'est
réduire la femme à son utérus et c'est
ensuite payé pour avoir un enfant c'est
marchandise c'est c'est c'est la
marchandisation de l'enfant c'est une
forme de traite humaine bien sûr qui est
interdite en France elle est pratiqué
les citoyens français y ont recours et
la circulaire tobira le facilite il y a
une hypocrisie majeure sur ce sujet
parler d'hypocrisie ceci dit dans les
textes en France ça n'existe pas c'est
interdit la circulaire tobira je vous
invite à lire la circulaire tobira et
d'ailleurs toutes les agences de
gestation pour autruit aujourd'hui sur
les accessibles depuis la France
d'origine d'agence étrangère he mais
mais tout en avant la circulaire tobira
en disant regardez c'est formidable en
France il y a plus aucun problème prenez
une mère porteuse et on va vous aider à
trouver une mère porteuse PMA GPA
mariage pour tous il y a beaucoup de
sujets mais celui de ce soir normalement
sur votre conférence desbas même si sans
doute on l'imagine la conversation va
glisser au fur à mesure de la soirée ce
sera sur le genre à l'école on va
utiliser les dernières minutes la
théorie du genre à l'école on va
utiliser les dernières minutes de cet
entretien pour pour en parler tout est
partie de ce mécontentement contre
l'ABCD de l'égalité plan gouvernemental
porté par Najat Valou Belkassem pour
lutter contre les stéréotypes filles
garçons à l'école qui est accusée que
vous accusez de purement et simplement
nier les différences entre les sexes on
peut pourtant imaginer qu'à la base on
lutte contre l'inégalité hommes-femm et
que c'est plutôt positif pas bien sûr
que c'est positif de lutter pour
l'égalité bien sûr le problème c'est que
quand on regarde les supports officiels
de l'éducation nationale ceux de la BCD
de l'égalité et ce qui est annoncé pour
le plan prétendument égalité c'est pas
de l'égalité c'est simplement la volonté
de considérer les élèves de manière
absolument neutre interchangeable comme
si garçon ou fille ça n'a aucune
importance ça n'a pas de sens pas
d'impact pas de conséquence et bien nous
nous disons que les enfants sont égaux
garçons et filles sont égaux et
différents et je peux vous donner des
exemples très concrets de ces supports
de ces de C lors de vos réunions
justement c'est rapporté par France
Télévision on peut retrouver l'article
sur leur site internet mais vous
expliquez aux parents que certains
enseignants parl de masturbation de
prostitution non ça c'est pas la manif
pour tous et ça n'est pas non plus notre
association magnifque pour tous c'est ce
que rapporte France Télévision les
journalistes pourra y avoir assisté je
n'ai jamais parlé de de de masturbation
ou autre que les enseignants que les
enseignants parl ça non vous confondez
pardonnez-moi avec un mouvement avec un
autre mouvement ça n'est pas la manif
pour tous et ça n'est pas non plus Vig
dans l'article et bien écoutez vous
allez me le montrer parce que l'article
fait une confusion ce que je dis
beaucoup plus simplement c'est que un
sur la BCD de l'égalité tout ce qui est
féminin et dévalorisé par exemple jouer
à la poupée ça n'a pas d'intérêt il vaut
mieux jouer au ballon les filières dites
féminines
sont méprisables ce qui est intéressant
c'est les filières dites masculines et
cetera et cetera donc un on est
absolument dans l'antiféminisme dans
l'antiemme l'idéal c'est l'homme et
l'idéal c'est que la femme soit un homme
comme les autres moi je regrette les
métiers qu'on appelle ducer si c'est ce
que les filles préfèrent pour une partie
ce sont des très beaux métiers après
Dieu merci elles sont libres aujourd'hui
et elles doivent rester libres d'aller
aussi vers les filières scientifiques
mais c'est déjà le cas dans les fili
scientifique vous avez 30 % de filles si
les goûts sont différents on va pas on
ne peut pas sur les propos qui sont
tenus sur la façon dont se déroule ces
ces réunions vous nêtes pas vous n'êtes
pas là pour faire peur non plus aux
familles aux parents leur disant faites
attention on parle d'homosexualité à vos
enfants mon propos vous avez entendu ça
n'est pas mon propos moi ce que je fais
dans ce que nous faisons dans ces
conféren très simple nous montrons les
supports de la BCD de l'égalité nous
montrons les citations nous passons des
vidéos à chacun de se faire sa propre
idée et jamais nous n'avons évoqué
ce que vous disiez la promotion de
l'homosexualité et tout le sujet c'est
bien
est-on dans un programme qui est
vraiment pour l'égalité entre les sexes
l'égalité c'est de reconnaître les
différences si on est dans la dans le
dénis des différences et puis aussi des
différence d'une personne à une autre
bien entendu alors on ne peut pas être
dans une véritable égalité je vais vous
donner un autre exemple dans laabcd il
est demandé enfin dans ce la suite de ce
programme les enseignants après avoir
été formés doivent s'autoévaluer dans la
grille d'auto évaluation de l'Académie
de créteille on lit ceci donc c'est
l'enseignant qui s'interroge fais-je
référence à mon identité sexuelle à
celle des élèves en quoi cela pose-t-il
problème de faire référence à l'école au
fait que oui l'humanité est homme femme
que moi je suis une femme que vous êtes
un homme et cetera en quoi cela
pose-t-il problème c'est quand même
extraordinaire et puis autre moyen pour
soit-disant l'égalité c'est déconstruire
les stéréotypes de genre alors on veut
déconstruire auprès d'enfants de jeunes
enfants en cours de construction et on
parle de stéréotype de genre pas sexuel
de genre déjà mais stéréotype mais c'est
très positif c'est quoi un stéréotype
c'est l'expression c'est ce que vous
c'est ce qu'on perçoit de vous à travers
votre masculinité ou fémininité alors il
y a des stéréotypes bien sûr qu'il faut
combattre c'est-à-dire qu'il faut
inviter et éduquer au resp poursuive
Jere il y a bien des stéréotypes les
stéréotypes sont également nécessaires
pour savoir qui on est pour qu'on sache
qui est l'autre et pour aussi que
l'autre sache à qui il a à faire c'est
débat sur ce thème en tout cas ce soir
au chaîn merci ludovine de la recher
d'être passé sur ce plateau avant de
vous rendre au chest à 20h30 ce soir
dans les locaux de l'ancienne Merri
merci à vous on parle à nouveau du
retour de Nicolas Sarkozi pour la suite
de ce journal dans les ivblines il
pourra notamment compter sur le soutien
je vous le disais en titre d' Rore
berger conseillère municipal
d'opposition Manamo que l'on dit proche
de l'ancien président en revanche la
chef de fil de l'UMP dans les ivelines
Valérie PC c'est plus
mesuré Nicolas Sarkozi entend reprendre
la tête tête de l'UMP lors de l'élection
interne du 29 novembre et pourquoi pas
de la France lors de la présidentielle
de 2017 un retour qui divise jusque dans
les rangs de sa famille politique député
desvelin ancienne ministre de
l'Éducation Valérie PCR estime qu'un
temps de réflexion lui serait nécessaire
avant d'accorder son soutien à l'ancien
président de la République et d'ajouter
lors d'un discours à la tribune ce
weekend nous avons besoin de
renouvellement de diversité et de
féminisation pour son retour Nicolas
Sarkozi s'est en tout cas entouré de
nouveaux visages et parmi eux Aurore
berger conseillère municipal
d'opposition à Man et à elle avait fait
campagne lors du dernier vote interne de
l'UMP au côté de Valérie PC derrière
François fill vous aur ch Nicolas SAR
n'était pas candidat à l'époque François
Fillon l'était donc il fallait faire un
choix à l'époque entre jean-fançois Copé
et François Fillon et mon choix cétait
porté à ce momentl pour François Fillon
je suis quelqu'un de libre avec une
autonomie de pensée de jugement d'action
et donc je fais mes propres choix je ne
me positionne pas par rapport au
d'autres on est un certain nombre
notamment dans la jeune génération à
être plutôt proche de Nicolas Sarkozi
avoir souhaité son retour et à
travailler pour qu'il puisse revenir
donc là on est en train de se mettre en
marche de mettre l'équipe en marche moi
je l'ai vu plusieurs fois je vais le
revoir cette semaine donc j'ai pas plus
d'élément à vous apporter à part de vous
dire que je suis enthousiaste à l'idé de
faire cette campagne pour lui les élus
locaux des ivelines semblent aussi avoir
apprécié les déclarations de Nicolas
Sarkozi Pierre Bédier président du
conseil général lui assure son soutien
tot tout comme le jeune maire UMP de
morpa Grégory garestier commentant en
direct sur les réseaux sociaux son
intervention sur France 2 pour l'ancien
député de la 11e circonscription et mer
des lancours même enthousiasme sur
Twitter Jean-Michel Fourgous évoque
expérience et
renouveau brillant certainement le
meilleur le meilleur d'entre nous
d'Urs je pense que l' est le pire
d'entre nous et je pense que Sarko en
classe politique de ce niveau c'est le
meilleur d'entre nous bon maintenant il
a son caractère il sait il a ses côté
agaçant mais mais il a une énergie et un
talent qui qui enorme don dont
aujourd'hui on a pas besoin on a plus
moins de se priver pour sortir le pays
de la situation dans lequel il est bien
sûr il a une énergie exceptionnelle on
l'a revu son énergie est intacte on l'a
bien vu sur le plateau euh et puis de
toute façon la France elle a besoin d'un
leader elle a besoin d'un vrai décideur
il son très content de son retour
surtout en plus que l'UMP il y avait
quand même un certain bazar on va pas se
le cacher donc voilà on sent bien que le
que bon il y a un vrai patron qui qui
est de retour prochaine étape pour
Nicolas Sarkozi un meeting de campagne
dans le pas decalis jeudi soir histoire
d'occuper le plus possible l'espace
médiatique face à ses
opposants et que pensez-vous du retour
de Nicolas Sarkozi si l'on en croit les
sondages moins d'un Français sur deux
est convaincu de sa prestation dimanche
soir on vous écoute dans les rues
saint-quanttin en il Sarkozi même combat
que qu'avant de toute façon ça change ça
change rien de tout ce qu'il a pu
raconter avant et maintenant ça pareil
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait quand il était au
pouvoir et 5 ans avec Chirac le chômage
est toujours pareil hein non je n'aime
pas je pense que c'était pour le moins
attendu donc c'est une confirmation de
ce que tout le monde savait déjà je
pense que pour la France ça peut être un
une bonne solution compte tenu de la
situation actuelle que l'on vit voilà je
trouve que c'est une calamité pour
quelle raison parce que on est en train
de passer de la démocratie au système de
l'homme providentiel pe j'apprécie pas
trop mais bon c'est son choix il a le
droit nous parlons à présent des
journées du patrimoine revu et corrigé
par les collectifs des amis de la
revanche ils ont organisé une marche ce
samedi sur les hauteurs de la colline
d'élencour pour dénoncer ce projet de
construction d'un skiome cette piste de
ski couverte une quinzaine de personnes
étaient présentes Catherine sulato
Patrick Jacques de
dixmud une vue imprenable sur 50 ans en
Yveline la clé de Saint-Pierre à hencour
voilà ce que ses membres du collectif
des amis de la revanche aimerait
conserver alors qu'un projet de piste de
ski artificiel est à l'étude sur la
colline une vieille idée d'avant le choc
pétrolier une vieille idée on a un point
culminant qu'est-ce qu'on peut en faire
on peut rêver de faire des skis mais
dans la réalité aujourd'hui euh c'est
vraiment plus du tout une bonne idée il
faut mettre les idées au goût du jour
c'est un projet qui a des gros
inconvénients économiques à chaque fois
qu'il y a eu un skidome quelque part il
a coulé ça coûte trop cher en énergie
alors on nous promet de l'emploi mais
c'est pas de l'emploi durable il y aura
des petits emplois parmi les membres du
collectif Claude stassinet un élen
courtois de la première heure en haut de
la colline d'élencour ce samedi en écho
au journé du patrimoine il expose ce
quétait la colline à l'origine une
simple plaine qui a reçu les déchets et
les dépôts de construction de la ville
nouvelle le skidome c'est son nouveau
combat le skidome d'abord ça sera une
balafre par rapport à la la colline un
hangar qui est à 5 degr toute l'année de
22000 m² donc 2 2 hectares d' ça
correspond à une consommation énergique
tique complètement fulgurante et c'est
irrecevable totalement irrecevable le
collectif des amis de la revanche est né
cet été après une réunion publique
organisé par la ville d'élancour dans le
cadre de la modification du plan local
d'urbanisme en vue de rendre une partie
de la commune constructible ce projet
pour l'heure est porté par un promoteur
hollandais qui pourrait investir près de
50 millions d'euros pour réaliser des
pistes de skis artificielles de 100 à
320 m selon le maire d'élancour
Jean-Michel Fourgous interrogé par nos
confrères du Figaro le projet pourrait
génér 200 emplois et attiré 300000
visiteurs par an les membres du
collectif restent eux mobilisés ils
distribueront des tractes lors des
marchés de la prochaine fête d'automne
et prépare des actions surprises le
collectif compte une cinquantaine
d'adhérents et aurait collecté quelques
2000 signatures lae
de à la colline à la colline des cour
les journées du patrimoine 31e édition
donc ce weekend rarement accessible au
public c'est le château de la verrière
qui a ouvert ses portes de la petite
chapelle au boiseries anciennes les
visiteurs ont découvert les secrets de
cet établissement devenu propriété de la
MG yolen Torz Patrick Jacques de dixmud
pour les images au fur à mesure du temps
et qui aujourd'hui pour ce qui est de
l'Intérieur date du 20e siècle car donc
vous allez voir tout ça c'était l'une
des nouveauté cette année lors des 31e
journées du patrimoine le château de La
Verrière a ouvert ses portes au public
débuté au 16e siècle par la famille
Séguier la construction du château
s'achève au 17e siècle époque où les
jardins auraient bénéficié de
l'attention toute particul du paysagiste
de Louis XIV on n pas de preuve
d'attribution à le NRE mais il y a
différents indices qui se rejoignent
pour faire penser que ça serait tout à
fait possible la famille seg étant très
impuissante et très influence que que le
nôtre est travaillé à ce parc à ce
jardin le bâtiment connaît ensuite
plusieurs propriétaires avant d'être
racheté en 1952 par la Mutuelle générale
de l'éducation nationale qui le
transforme en hôpital psychiatrique
autant d'histoires qui font de ce
château un héritage intéressant c'est
probablement la première fois autant que
je puisse le savoir
donc voilà on avait envie de connaître
un peu notre patrimoine locale bon la
chapelle est surprenante ça c'est
évident puisquelle est quand même assez
c'est peu une association d'un certain
nombre de styles bon elle est récente
mais
effectivement bon c'est surprenant c'est
plutôt la la cuisine ancienne là qui est
assez typique
du certainement original du château
aujourd'hui une partie de ces jardins
est protégé au titre des monuments
historiques et le château sert de centre
de formation à la
MGEN merci de nous avoir suivi le
journal revient demain aux mêmes heures
bonne
soirée